ما هو الهدف الذي تنوون تحقيقه في مثل هذه
الاماكن التي تعاني من عدم الاستقرار في
المنطقه العربيه
عندما تم تحديد مدن من سيطره داعش كان
برنامجنا وقتها يعمل مع الحكومه العراقيه
على برنامج استقرار رئيسى يتكلف مليارات
الدولارات ويضم الاف المشاريع الصغيره
لخلق الوظائف للاشخاص لتشجيعهم على العوده
الى قراهم ومدنهم التي دمرت جزئيا وتتضمن
دعم العوده بامور بسيطه مثل اعاده بناء
سقف او حمام منزل او اعاده ربطه بالماء او
الكهرباء او بكليهما لذلك فان الالاف من
هذه المشاريع بالتنسيق مع المجالس المحليه
والتجمعات المتضرره سمحت لما لا يقل عن
اربعه ملايين ونصف المليون كانوا مشردين
داخليا العوده في غضون سته شهور بعد تحرير
مناطقهم بدلا من ان يبقوا عالقين لسنوات
في مخيمات هذه هي الصوره التي توضح معنى
التدخل العاجل الناجع والبعيد عن
البيروقراطيه والتي سمحت عبر برامج عمليه
لملايين الاشخاص باعاده بناء تجمعاتهم كل
شخص يرغب بالعوده الى دياره لكن اذا لم
يكن لديك مدرسه او كهرباء او ما او
الاساسيات التي تسمح لك بالعيش فانك لن
تعود برنامج الامم المتحده الاملائيه
وقتها بدعم من الاسره الدوليه والسلطات
المحليه ايضا وخاصه نجح في احداث فارق
هائل وهذا هو تحديدا ما نرغب بجلبه
للمناطق التي تعيش ازمات ونعمل الان في
المنطقه في دول مثل اليمن وفي لبنان الذي
يعيش وضع اقتصاديا حرجا للغايه اين نساعد
مؤسسات الدوله هناك على الحفاظ على
وظائفها الاساسيه بما يس اعدها على اداء
مهامها في العراق نجحنا بعد النزاع الاول
في احداث الفارق وامنوا ان يستمر البرنامج
في العمل مع الدول المجاوره التي ترغب
برؤيه جيرانها لا تعاني من مثل هذه الظروف
نحن شريك موثوق وكفر نعمل تحت مظله الامم
المتحده على ضمان ان لا تتعقد الاوضاع
اكثر